I'm here in Harvard art museums in front
of an exquisitely beautiful virgin and
child painted by Sandro Botticelli the
legendary Florentine painter but it
surely was part of a chain of artistic
genius that flourished in Renaissance
Florence it starts when Brunelleschi
figures out the basic mathematics of
linear perspective how to make
two-dimensional surfaces appear
three-dimensional he passes that wisdom
along to his friend Donatello
who puts it on the wall of Awesome
Akeley and lower leaf sculpture
Donatello passes along to Masato who
paints the brunt catchy Chappell
marvelous painting of Saint Peter
finding a silver coin in the belly of a
fish according to Vasari
FRA Filippo Lippi at less than saintly
monk learns his craft by sitting at the
feet of masaccio Lippe was the teacher
of Botticelli and perhaps we see the
influence of lippies beautiful Madonna's
in the Madonna behind us this was a
chain of artistic greatness brought
together by the city of Florence but
this painting isn't just another
beautiful Madonna and Child by
Botticelli there something special about
it look at the buildings look at their
roofs look at the crow Gables these are
northern roofs the kind of roofs you
would see in Copenhagen or Amsterdam of
Bruges they're not roofs that you would
see in Florence or Naples or Rome it's
quite possible that this painting was
crafted by the master of Gothic
buildings a northern painter who came
south to work with Botticelli and in a
sense this painting symbolizes the deep
connections between the northern and
southern Renaissance the north which
gave us the detailed oil painting of Van
Eyck in Vanderheiden the south which
gave us linear perspective and the
glories of da Vinci and Raphael these
two Renaissance came together in part
because these two great urban
civilizations that at the Low Countries
and that of central Italy were tied so
closely by common interests in my trade
in the 15th century the north and the
south looked very similar they were both
free places of Commerce and creativity
places where artistic genius flourished
two centuries later the North was still
at it
Amsterdam was the center of a great
trading empire still churning out
artistic masterpieces like Rembrandt's
Night Watch while Florence had sunk into
somnolence one reason for this is
political
Amsterdam had won its freedom in a
hard-fought 60 revolt against their
Hofstra overlords Florence had become a
petty principality the Medicis had moved
from being merchant princes the first
among equals were eager to court
popularity by sponsoring great artists
to becoming petty despots resting on
their laurels and so the greatness of
Florence faded and yet it is still here
that legacy of 15th century Glory which
reminds us of the miracles that happen
when people come together and are
connected by cities
you